my administration i'm going to enforce
all laws concerning
the protection of classified information
no one
will be above the law
okay now we know the crimes that the doj
thinks former president trump committed
when the fbi served a search warrant on
donald trump's florida club the reaction
was shock and outrage what records could
trump have that would justify a raid on
the ex-president's home well now we know
that reports indicate that the fbi was
sent to retrieve documents in part
related to nuclear weapons
and although we don't know what was in
the dozens of boxes removed from
mar-a-lago we do know that jay bratt was
present for the search brat is the fbi's
chief of counterintelligence and export
control that probably means that yes
trump had information related to nuclear
weapons or national defense this is a
really big deal because presidents do
not have the right to classify or
declassify records relating to nuclear
information we'll get into that in a
second and now we have the benefit of
the actual warrant that was served on
trump's estate so in this video we're
going to take a deep dive into the
crimes that former president trump may
have violated by taking a u-haul full of
documents to his basement in palm beach
but here's what we know so far on friday
morning trump sent messages by truth
social insisting that the quote nuclear
weapons issue is a hoax he also
suggested that barack hussein obama had
lots of nuclear information that he had
used for his library he also once again
accused the fbi of planting information
and almost at the same time he's claimed
that he had a standing order to
declassify all information taken out of
the white house which seems to run
contrary to his allegation that the fbi
planted the information that he
seemingly declassified uh it has been
alleged that mar-a-lago does have
security cameras so there is a
possibility that the search might have
been recorded now meanwhile eric trump
did what trump's do best he asked people
to donate money if they're mad and now
after a week of speculation we have the
actual search warrant that was served
which is fairly unusual because these
things tend to stay sealed so why was it
the case that the court unsealed it well
according to the new york times the
government first tried to convince trump
to simply return the records at issue
when he did not comply the government
served trump with a subpoena to return
the boxes trump apparently only
partially responded to the subpoena so
the doj decided to get a search warrant
to get the rest of the records the
washington post has reported the fbi
sought among other items classified
documents related to nuclear weapons
attorney general eric garland held a
press conference on thursday where he
confirmed three things first that he
approved the warrants in accordance with
the memo on political targets for more
information about that memo which
originated with trump's attorney general
bill barr check out my other video on
the trump search warrant now second the
doj filed a motion with the district
court to unseal the warrant application
and the warrant itself that made the two
documents public although it did not
unseal the probable cause affidavit that
gave rise to the warrant itself uh and
third the the search warrant and the
return were left with trump's lawyers in
accordance with the federal rules of
civil procedure so now we can examine
the unsealed warrant itself according to
the search warrant the property to be
seized included quote all physical
documents and records constituting
evidence contraband fruits of crime or
other items illegally possessed in
violation of 18 usc sections 793 2071 or
1519. so this means that trump is being
investigated under the following
statutes ac and usc 2071 which prohibits
the concealment removal or mutilation of
information 18 usc 793 which prohibits
gathering transmitting or losing defense
information and 18 usc 1519 which
outlaws the destruction alteration or
falsification of records in federal
investigations trump's lawyers have
argued that trump had a right to
declassify all these records and that he
did so before he left office however
none of the three statutes require that
the information be classified in order
for it to be a crime and we'll talk
about that wrinkle in a second trump's
lawyer christina bob signed the receipt
listing the property that was removed
from mar-a-lago the fbi took about 20
boxes of records photographs binders and
handwritten notes the list starts with
clemency records related to roger stone
and quote info ray the president of
france they removed 11 sets of
classified documents some of these were
marked top secret and were only allowed
to be stored in special government
facilities it also says agents collected
four sets of top secret documents three
sets of secret documents and three sets
of confidential documents allowing the
fbi to win their game of federal gin
rummy now the list of documents includes
records marked various classified tssci
documents and this abbreviation refers
to top secret and sensitive
compartmented information now sensitive
compartment information is information
about certain intelligence sources and
methods and can include information
pertaining to sensitive collection
systems analytical processing and
targeting or things that are derived
from it now a person can only have
access to sei if they have a top secret
security clearance and if they have a
need to know designation although the
president has access to sei that doesn't
necessarily mean he has the authority to
remove sei documents and store them in
his house after he's no longer president
and since the boxes of records recovered
from mar-a-lago do seem to relate to
national defense
i turn to one of the pre-eminent
national security lawyers in the country
and coincidentally the lawyer who is
currently litigating my federal cases
regarding john bolton's memoir and the
inspector general misconduct in the last
administration kell mcclanahan
so kel
what could it mean if trump has or
withheld national security information
well once national security information
is involved that's a completely
different ball game and it doesn't even
have to be classified information the
espn object which i'm sure most of your
viewers are familiar with doesn't
require something to be classified
before it heavily penalizes people who
take it who hide it to destroy it to
keep it in their basement
it just requires that something be
called national defense information
which is helpfully defined as
information related to the national
defense that extraordinarily broad
definition
allows people to be prosecuted under the
espionage act for taking information
that is not classified as long as it has
something to do with the national
defense
and when you have classified information
well that triggers a different law
called 18 usc 1924 which used to be a
misdemeanor that people pled down to for
mishandling classified information
but president trump himself signed a law
in 2018 that made it a felony so that
all they have to prove is that there was
classified information
he did not store it properly
therefore he's guilty it's as close to a
strict liability crime as you generally
get in the intelligence community and so
kel there are also reports that the
documents could relate to nuclear
weapons if that's true how does that
change things well the involvement of
nuclear weapons information throws a
whole new variable into the mix you see
what we think of as classified
information is actually a creation of an
executive order that is the control of
the classification
is the exclusive domain of the president
and the executive branch the president
can classify it the president can
declassify however
nuclear weapons information is one of
the few types of information that's
controlled by statute in this case the
atomic energy act
and the statute says that this
information cannot be released or
disseminated without going through a
certain set of steps
and that is not within the exclusive
control of the president therefore
even if trump had said that he
declassified this information before he
took it home with him that wouldn't be
enough he would have declassified it for
the purposes of the executive order but
he would still be bound by the atomic
energy act which carries its own
criminal penalties
thanks a lot cal kell runs the national
security councilor and does great work
including legal attempts to recover the
secret service and dhs leadership text
messages that were illegally deleted
last year that you've no doubt read
about in the news and a tax-deductible
donation to the nsc would go a long way
since they're handling many cases
including my own pro bono so there's a
link to that down in the description so
that's the information and documents
that are at issue in this investigation
but let's look at the actual crimes that
are being investigated the first is 18
usc 1519 the destruction alteration or
falsification of records in federal
investigations it states whoever
knowingly alters destroys mutilates
conceals covers up falsifies or makes a
false entry in any record document or
tangible object with the intent to
impede obstruct or influence the
investigation or proper administration
of any matter within the jurisdiction of
any department or agency of the united
states shall be fined under this title
in prison not more than 20 years or both
so in other words to convict a defendant
of obstruction under section 1519 the
government has to prove each of the
following elements first that the
defendant knowingly altered destroyed
concealed or falsified a record document
or tangible object and second the
defendant acted with the intent to
impede obstruct or influence an actual
or contemplated investigation of a
matter within the jurisdiction of an
agency of the united states now the
government doesn't have to prove the
defendant's sole or even primary
intention was to obstruct justice as
long as the government proves beyond a
reasonable doubt that one of the
defendant's intentions was to obstruct
justice but that takes us to 8 usc 2071
which prohibits the willful concealment
destruction or removal of federal
documents to establish a violation of
this provision the government must prove
one an individual concealed removed or
destroyed a record or attempted to do so
or took and carried away a record with
the intent to do so the record was filed
or deposited in a public office of the
united states and the individual acted
willfully and unlawfully now note that
this is a specific intent crime that
requires a person to have had an
intention to destroy or remove the
records in violation of these laws and
is often the case with these specific
intent crimes trump might be able to
argue that he didn't know he wasn't
allowed to remove the documents or
destroy them although there's certainly
evidence that he was repeatedly told he
was violating the law with the way that
he handled records the washington post
reported that two of trump's former
chiefs of staff reince priebus and john
kelly and former white house counsel don
mcgann warned him about the presidential
records act when it comes to a potential
violation of 18 usc 2071 there is an
additional wrinkle because that section
ostensibly prohibits someone from
running from office now i take a deep
dive into that language the case law and
the potential repercussions for former
president trump in a video that's
exclusive to nebula that i'll talk about
in a little while but that takes us to
18 usc 793 which concerns the gathering
transmitting or losing defense
information section 793 is known as the
espionage act which covers the unlawful
retention of defense-related information
which could harm the united states or an
ally now the espionage act is a bit of a
misnomer it's not really or most of it
is not about espionage it's really about
state secrets now section 793d makes it
a crime for anyone quote lawfully having
possession of access to control over or
being entrusted with any of a range of
tangible items or information relating
to the national defense which
information the possessor has reason to
believe could be used to the injury of
the united states or to the advantage of
any foreign nation willfully
communicates delivers transmits or
causes or attempts the same to any
person not entitled to receive it or
willfully retains the same and fails to
deliver it on demand to the officer or
employee of the united states entitled
to receive it in other words it's a
crime to leak national security
information section 793-f makes it a
crime for government officials who have
lawful possession of such materials to
remove them or disclose them to third
parties who are unauthorized to receive
them to be guilty of this offense the
person has to have disclosing
information due to their own gross
negligence or because of their failure
to report the information lost or stolen
but the espionage act is not limited to
just those people who wrongfully
disclose national defense information
section 793e also says it applies to
anyone who knowingly disseminates
distributes or even retains national
defense information without immediately
returning the material to the government
officer authorized to possess it in
other words the text of the act draws no
distinction between the leaker the
recipient of the link or the 100th
person to redistribute retransmit or
even retain the national defense
information that by that point is
already in the public domain so
basically the entire staff of mar-a-lago
should probably lawyer up at this point
and if the person who is charged under
the act knows or has reason to believe
that the information in their possession
relates to the national defense and
could be used to injure the united
states or benefit a foreign power that
person is violating the act's plain
language regardless of their specific
intent so that means that almost anyone
in the chain could be prosecuted under
this section the leaker who in this case
would be the ex-president
his son
son-in-law a journalist or even one of
trump's lawyers now there is one crime
that isn't mentioned in the search
warrant and that is a violation of the
presidential records act and there's a
very good reason for why the pra is not
mentioned in the search warrant so let's
talk about a president and former
president's responsibility under the pra
section 2203 of the act gives the
president the responsibility of
identifying preserving records during
the administration and requires the
president to take all such steps as may
be necessary to preserve presidential
records however a president may also
destroy records that the president
decides quote no longer have
administrative historical informational
or evidentiary value before destroying
records the president must ask the
archivist for their opinion although the
archivist can give an opinion the person
can't stop the president from making
their own call and if the archivist does
not sign off on the president's
determination congressional
subcommittees are notified but it's
unclear what congress can actually do
during such a dispute the statute is
murky and vague which brings up the most
important point about the pra it lacks a
real enforcement mechanism although the
president is not supposed to rip up
records shred them or flush them down
the toilet the pra is at most a
statement of best practices like an
honor system this was illustrated early
in trump's tenure when crew challenged
trump's record-keeping practices by
suing him under the pra crew alleged
that trump deleted tweets and violation
the pra and that the white house use of
encrypted and auto deleting messages uh
hindered the ability of federal agencies
to perform their duties the lawsuit
sought a court order compelling the
president to stop auto-deleting messages
and preserve them under the pra but the
dc circuit dismissed cruz's lawsuit
interpreting the president's
record-keeping duties narrowly the court
held that mandamus relief was only
available under extraordinary
circumstances and that a president's
record-keeping duties under the pra are
too discretionary to be enforced by
court order although courts can review
the classification of existing records a
court can't stop the president from
acting in other words the court held it
could not tell the president to create
and preserve particular records however
courts have been willing to enforce some
modest limits on what white house
officials can do with records that have
already been created crew successfully
sued dick cheney for failure to classify
some documents as presidential records a
district court also invalidated an
agreement between president h.w bush and
the national archives that would have
conferred complete control of
presidential records on the president
after he left office although citizens
don't have a right to enforce the pra
the department of justice arguably does
have a mandate to enforce the pra in
some circumstances crew in the national
security archive wrote to fbi director
chris wray and a.g merrick garland uh
and requested that they investigate
whether former president trump violated
criminal laws by willfully destroying
and mutilating his presidential records
while in office the national archives
also requested that the department of
justice undertake an investigation but
there are a number of criminal statutes
that make removal and destruction of
federal property a crime it is generally
illegal to remove property from the
white house for example in 2001 bill
clinton staffers removed the w key from
west wing keyboards right before george
w bush was inaugurated this prank was
actually theft and the general
accounting office interviewed over 100
government employees about the theft of
the ws so if the government decides to
charge trump with crimes related to
these documents what are trump's
defenses here well the first would
probably be declassification trump's
lawyers say that he had declassified the
documents at issue now presidents do
have broad plenary power to classify and
declassify documents that power stems
from their position as
commander-in-chief the president can
delegate this authority they can
exercise it themselves or they can order
the release of classified documents
after a certain period of time and as
far as we know barack obama was the last
president to issue an order on
classified information
under obama's executive order 13 526
original classification authorities like
the heads of various departments and
agencies were allowed to classify and
declassify information owned by their
organizations that means that
departments might authorize the
disclosure of information to someone
with a proper security clearance and
this executive order has not been
rescinded and federal agencies are still
following it however future and
following presidents like trump and
biden are under no obligation to follow
obama's executive order they can tweak
the order issue their own or simply
handle things in an ad hoc manner and
trump's approach to classified
information could probably be described
as freewheeling and after trump lost the
2020 election donald trump jr tweeted
that his dad should quote declassify
everything we can't let the bad actors
get away with it
could trump have declassified everything
i think deep in your heart you already
know the answer to that well technically
yes the president does have the power to
declassify every document that the us
government holds but then that
information would be public and you
could foia that information and release
it and trump's defenders in congress
held a press conference to explain that
not everything that is classified is
totally classified and in some ways what
they're saying actually does make sense
the government tends to overclassify
records and arguably a lot more
information should be available to the
public
transparency in government is generally
a good thing but in this case we may be
talking about some extremely sensitive
top secret information
information that may relate to nuclear
weapons and this gets us to one of the
main exceptions about the president's
declassification powers which is that
the president doesn't fully control
information about nuclear weapons the
atomic energy act regulates information
about nuclear weapons and nuclear energy
under the act restricted data and
formally restricted data are top secret
information and the act defines
restricted data as all data concerning
the design manufacture or utilization of
atomic weapons the production of special
nuclear material and the use of special
nuclear material in the production of
energy now nuclear information is placed
in the formerly restricted data category
after the department of energy and the
department of defense jointly determined
that it relates primarily to the
military utilization of atomic weapons
now the president also lacks control
over information related to u.s and
foreign intelligence operations the
intelligence identities protection act
protects the identity of covert u.s
intelligence operatives their identities
and other intelligence sources are
protected by statute and the president
cannot reveal them without breaking
federal law and there's also another
exception to the president's
declassification power which should be
completely obvious former presidents
don't have the legal authority to
declassify records after they leave
office but at base as noted earlier
declassifying the documents is only one
of the hurdles since a lot of the
statutes that issue here do not turn on
whether the information is classified
that's completely unrelated we also
don't know if trump followed the
procedure for declassifying the
documents he can't just think
declassification in his head while
president and the documents are
declassified the lawyers at just
security summarize the process for
declassification like this classified
documents have classification markings
in the header and footer of each page
indicating the level classification for
the document as a whole furthermore
classified records have cover sheets
that specifically indicate when the
record was classified by whom and under
what authority as well as when the
classification expires if trump did in
fact order the declassification he still
needed to make sure his staff took the
necessary next steps to modify the
classification markings on the documents
before he could actually handle and
store the records as a private citizen
as if they were unclassified under
security classification rules a
classification marking on a document has
to be treated as valid and binding
unless and until a subsequent marking
replaces it appropriate government
staffers would have needed to cross out
the classification markings in the
headers and footers and stamped
declassified on the record noting when
it was declassified by whom and under
what authority
since that does not appear to have been
done with the classified documents
reportedly identified to date the
documents remain classified and had to
be treated as classified for handling
and storage purposes it's probably worth
noting that ignorance is not going to be
a defense here because reportedly the
fbi and doj met with trump several times
issued a subpoena and not all of the
documents were given back and even the
fact that some of the documents were
given back initially
shows that they know how to handle
classified documents and
agreed that some of these documents
needed to be returned to the government
that being said trump might have a first
amendment defense the supreme court does
recognize that in some cases the
public's interest in receiving
information can outweigh the
government's interest in keeping it
secret however when evaluating first
amendment concerns the court gives more
leeway to reporters who lawfully obtain
government documents than they do to
government officials and
uh you know when you're talking about
classified and defense information or
information related to nuclear documents
security interests are probably going to
outweigh those first amendment concerns
so will this be the thing that brings
down the former president it's hard to
say but a lot of people have noticed
that a violation of section 2071 can
carry with it a penalty of being barred
from office could that be used to
prevent trump from running again well i
have an entire separate video over on
nebula exclusive to nebula which is
today's sponsor along with curiosity
stream because on nebula my videos
always come out early with zero ads and
i release exclusive content like this
all the time like this entire video on
whether trump can be barred from office
a video on alex jones's testimony
whether it amounts to perjury or not and
my first full-length documentary bad law
words good which is honestly hilarious
i'm really proud of it all of this
exclusive content is available only on
nebula which you can get for free with
curiosity stream nebula is creator owned
and creator operated and there's
exclusive new content released multiple
times every day by the internet's best
educational creators and by the way
we've been developing nebula like crazy
nebula now has apps for ios android
apple tv roku fire tv and android tv and
it was recently nominated for its first
streamy award my fellow creators and i
really care about nebula and we're
thrilled to be partnering with curiosity
stream because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries and long-form
educational content on the internet they
even have an entire section devoted to
unsolved mysteries and crime so if you
like my videos you'll love the thousands
of titles on curiosity stream and the
best way to get access to nebula and all
of the incredible content is through the
amazing curiosity stream nebula bundle
deal with its current sales price of
less than 15 per year to get full access
to both sites and to be clear that
nebulous subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member there just isn't
a better deal in streaming where you get
two great streaming sites with content
that you'll actually watch and enjoy for
less than fifteen dollars a year at the
current sales price so to get curiosity
stream and nebula for less than fifteen
dollars per year just click on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description it's a great way to
support educational content and get tons
of exclusive content that you'll love so
for less than fifteen dollars per year
click on the link that's on screen right
now or down in the description and after
that click on this playlist for more
legal eagle videos so click on this
playlist or i'll see you in court